[Música]
actualización de las noticias económicas
con Daniela Blandón Daniela un saludo
nuevamente Hola Ángela y vamos a empezar
por América Latina México nacionalizó el
litio Qué significa esta decisión para
el país bueno el litio es un codiciado
metal que da vida a los celulares a los
computadores también a los automóviles
eléctricos y el gobierno de Andrés
Manuel López Obrador acaba de firmar un
decreto para nacionalizar este mineral y
entregar todas sus reservas a la
secretaría de energía quiere decir que
la empresa creada para este efecto en
agosto pasado que se llama litio de
México será la encargada de desarrollar
estos recursos bien sea sola o en
Alianza con privados Aunque siempre
manteniendo una participación
mayoritaria porque es tan codiciado este
material Pues también lo están llamando
oro blanco o el petróleo del siglo XXI Y
es que su precio se ha multiplicado por
10 en apenas dos años y ya cuesta más de
60 mil dólares la tonelada sobre todo
gracias al Boom de los vehículos
eléctricos y Suramérica es la Fuente más
preciada de este recurso tiene más de la
mitad de las reservas mundiales
estimadas en 89 millones de toneladas
chile Argentina y Bolivia son conocidas
como el Triángulo del litio de
Suramérica pues poseen vastas reservas
esta le auge que el gobierno chileno de
Gabriel boric ha planteado la
posibilidad de nacionalizarlo como ya lo
hizo Bolivia y también ahora lo está
haciendo México el lado oscuro del litio
es que cada planta consume millones de
litros de agua por día un dolor de
cabeza para las comunidades agrícolas
que están muy afectadas por sequías en
esta zona un lado bien oscuro ahora en
otros temas de Daniela vamos a pasar a
la guerra de Rusia y Ucrania se cumple
un año de la invasión esta misma semana
y vamos a estar contando Cómo ha
cambiado la economía de los países
involucrados y también del resto del
mundo usted comienza con el ciudadano de
a pie de que está en Rusia No pues claro
sabemos que las sanciones occidentales
contra Moscú pues han estrangulado las
ganancias de los bancos también han
arruinado las operaciones
internacionales de muchos de los
prestamistas pero si la pregunta es que
tanto ha cambiado el panorama para
quienes hacen operaciones
en rublos la respuesta es no tanto
porque ya no se ven las largas filas en
cajeros como antes porque el Banco
Central ha impuesto controles de
capitales Y eso ha hecho que se evite la
fuga de dinero ahora hay más uso de
efectivos que de tarjetas porque las
grandes franquicias se han ido del país
viene y una de las preguntas que surgen
aquí es que ha pasado con las personas
que tenían dólares pues la situación es
bastante distinta en este caso para
aquellos que viajan al extranjero o
quienes tienen Divisas Pues los
principales bancos de Rusia fueron
expulsados del sistema global de pagos
Swift a quienes tenían dólares u otras
monedas extranjeras se les permitió
sacar lo equivalente de hasta Diez mil
dólares antes del 9 de marzo desde
entonces solamente han podido sacar en
rublos y aquellos que han viajado fuera
del país se les ha hecho mucho más
costosa la comisión para sacar su dinero
de Rusia Así que los más Aventureros
inclusive han acudido a otros métodos
como la inversión en criptomonedas
porque compran en rublos a través de las
plataformas y retiran en dólares y
nuestro otro tema tiene que ver con las
redes sociales porque Facebook e
Instagram van a empezar a cobrar las
cuentas verificadas Así es meta
platforms que es la matriz de estas
redes sociales y también de WhatsApp
inicio en Australia y en Nueva Zelanda
esta semana las pruebas para comenzar
este cobro de una suscripción mensual
para aquellos que quieran tener esa
famosa insignia azul el precio inicial
propuesto según el fundador de metamark
soccerberg será de 11,99 dólares
mensuales en la web también lo vemos
14,9 dólares por mes para iOS de Apple y
Android y esto se suma entonces a
Twitter que ya tenía un valor del
servicio de verificación conocido como
blue de 11 dólares por mes hay otras
aplicaciones como Snapchat y Telegram
que lanzaron sus servicios de
suscripción paga el año pasado todo eso
como una nueva fuente de ingresos y
Daniela Los indicadores bueno en general
Ángela se espera calma en los mercados
ya que Wall Street va a permanecer
cerrado por ser día festivo las que se
operaron fueron las bolsas asiáticas al
alza después de conocerse que china
mantendrá intacto sus tipos de interés
por sexto mes consecutivo en tres coma
sesenta y cinco por ciento y hablamos
también de monedas el dólar amaneció
bajando en todo el mundo Pero sigue muy
cerca de su máximo de seis semanas
alcanzado el viernes y es que los datos
que se han conocido recientemente
apuntan a que la reserva Federal va a
mantener su estricta política de alzas
de interés en Irán por su parte la
moneda local Se desplomó hoy a un nuevo
mínimo histórico de 500 un mil
trescientos reales por dólar con los
iraníes comprando dólares
desesperadamente para buscar Un refugio
para sus ahorros en medio de esta fuerte
crisis económica y de las acciones
sanciones occidentales Daniela gracias a
usted y por adaptarse al orden de mis